never hold back in what it is you do and
think beyond what is possible I'm
Michael Martin the CEO of rapid SOS and
I'm 29 years old every day across this
country half a million Americans call
9-1-1 facing some of the most
challenging circumstances of their lives
and despite all the ways that technology
has transformed our lives those calls
are going through this this 1960s
infrastructure still so we're way to
transmit rich data directly into first
responders and then we actually harness
that data to predict and preempt
emergencies before they occur I was a
kind of Midwestern er from the middle of
nowhere that came to New York City and
had this my big welcome to New York
mugging I think it could hit the
rite-of-passage probably so I was
walking home really late one night on
111th Street in East Harlem and was
followed and that was the first moment
where I realize just in the middle of
these circumstances how hard it is it's
like saying timeout like let me get out
my phone dial a number explain where I
am et cetera so it's something that
occurs for millions of Americans every
year is just this challenge in these
emergencies we now live in the 21st
century with smartphones we know exactly
where we're located what's occurring all
this new real-time data but none of that
can get into the hands of first
responders today so in the middle of
your heart attack in the middle of an
assault in the middle of a kidnapping if
you can't provide an address and exactly
what is occurring it's very difficulty
so we are this ability to push all that
data directly in the first
an emergency
[Music]
we're working with wearables companies
on monitoring your health so the future
is if you stop breathing in the mill the
night or if you have a heart attack or
health emergency you won't even have to
think about it we can transmit all that
data directly into an ambulance or first
responders and longer-term we're
actually working on how we can use that
data to predict and preempt events
before they occur and we quickly realize
like wow if all this data there's
patterns and there's trends if it's
raining at a certain rate water pools in
certain sections of i-95 and you get
more car accidents there so we can now
actually see all that information and we
can now start to warn you and guide you
and adjust traffic patterns and things
like that about that data cell I stay
awake over excitement of all the things
that that we have going on
the nature of being an entrepreneur is
that you're constantly coming up with
challenges and roadblocks along the way
you have to really believe and care
about what it is that you're doing in
health care particularly that way it's
giant bureaucracies it's antiquated
infrastructure and believing in that
mission and having the passion to see it
through is is essential